Louisiana is a startling place to be you
know firstly it's the sort of complex
perversity of some of the locations in
the and the plantations are that you're
struck by this extraordinary beauty of
these places and you're aware of what
has happened and what is occurred there
there's this you know the woodland areas
the Bayou obviously are stunning to look
at and you know and then and then the
life is that there's this the kind of
heat you know our first day of shooting
was 108 degrees high humidity picking
cotton out in the plantation on the
apps' plantation and and suddenly that
sense that you know you're really kind
of deep within this world you know
you're deep you've slipped down the
rabbit hole somehow and and then you're
struck by the kind of reality of this
thing it's a very raw environment it's
the environment is already emotional and
then obviously what is occurring there
is adds another level to that so it's I
don't know I think I went back you know
you know when you go to the book and and
Solomon northup's book and he talks
about the environment at length and and
and only when you're there really do you
really connect in a in a way in a
different way in a deeper way somehow to
to what he's to what he experienced you
know from very early on in the
discussions we we didn't want it to look
like a documentary we didn't want it to
you know we wanted it to look real but
there was no point in there making it
gritty and also it was felt that this
this beauty would be a fantastic
counterpoint to the horror and we were
lucky the locations were you know they
were beautiful and one of the things
that Steve and I discussed from the
beginning was a very painterly approach
to the film and you know
been choosing the aspect ratio we chose
you know usually the two four of that
widescreen gives you an amazing palette
for a composition and the choice of the
locations the amazing work by Adam
Stockhausen the designer you know all of
those things go together and you cannot
help but make it beautiful because it
was the most horrific things happen the
most beautiful places that was the thing
that sort of that was constant for me
and what was interesting about these
plantations was that the sort of you
know the left to the elements and not
some of them are not particularly looked
after or they should be some kind of
natural trust but filming those real
locations you you you you felt the
presence of the past we were dancing
with ghosts when you're shooting there
when you first come on to a plantation
and I'm saying african-american woman
but also my Caucasian girlfriends that
would be in the same pictures as an
American you you start to come down the
road and you just get full of something
you get emotional even if you're not
thinking about it something happens and
I think it is it is the history not in
terms of the recorded occurrence but
it's in it's in our cultural DNA and you
feel it and Steve you said ghost it is
it's a communal experience and it is
things are passed on to you whether you
know them or not and so you feel that
it's very emotional you weep you don't
think you can do it and you have to
really shut your mind off probably the
same way that people that had to live
and had to to love and to keep going had
to just keep going and you're just
you're there just for a while
I think the job of an artist is we feel
that a lot more you see a lot more Sean
than even I see when I walk in there but
your job your discipline kicks in and
you realize that that the point is you
have to honor that
you have to channel that by being as
truthful and as specific and that
actually there's a thing that feeds you
and it then it becomes a trance a
transformative thing where it is sacred
and it is joyful in a way and you feel
you feel connected I went to drama
school to stretch myself to try and just
to make myself more elastic so that I
could be a better actor and that was
what I went through for three years they
threw me into all sorts of uncomfortable
places so when I received the script and
was auditioning for Patsy it was a dream
come true you know a character that
asked me to be joyful and completely
sorrowful at the same time and to do it
in such a way that those things weren't
at odds about a week before we started
shooting I was always you know I when
I'm working on a character I'm always
trying to lift it off the page and make
understand the person further than what
the just is on the page and so I was
daydreaming in my hotel room about what
Patsy would do in the little three time
she had and the fact that she picked 500
pounds of cotton a day struck me as
someone who was obviously had very
nimble fingers and was probably artistic
and so I was thinking about that and I
knew that Epps grew corn on his
plantation so I was like Oh what if she
made some something out of the corn husk
and so I quickly looked it up online and
it was historically accurate that slaves
did make crafts from corn husk and so I
the next day I had a rehearsal with
Steve and we were just talking about the
character and I I shared it with him and
he loved the idea and got the art
department to supply me with corn husk
that very day and you know I I wish I do
feel like it was Patsy's guidance to to
that revelation because it really did
kind of come from nowhere
yeah it is a large book and the in
approach I think all of us probably
wanted to be reductive and not additive
and not try to create things or add
something from a 2013 mindset but really
be faithful to the material and I would
encourage everyone to read it because it
really is one of the most phenomenal
documents that I've had the opportunity
to read I wouldn't be the first person
to say I was embarrassed and not have
known about it prior to that but it has
been a real honor to be part of a group
of people who restored it to a place of
prominence in American literature you
know communication is something that we
certainly take for granted in 2013 but
it was an irony in the book that he
could have written the letter and left
it to his wife and she would have had an
inkling of where he was and what was
going on I also think that it really
spoke to the totality of Solomon someone
used every part of himself his wits as
guy was physicality to survive and to
try to find these ways to create ink and
quill and to steal paper just
fundamental aspects over a long period
of time to survive and let people know
who he was I think was a marvelous
attribute and one that in particular in
the conversations we really wanted to
underscore was what this gentleman was
all about I always felt you know in a
funny way it wasn't a period piece it
was something a conversation we needed
to have now and I work with the music I
wanted I wanted the music to be off from
now so that this conversation would take
place now because I think I don't know I
think Steve and I we work very
instinctively together I mean the
conversations we have about feelings
they're not they're not about history
and and I think within just like music
just like music is you know you can't
really talk about it you can sort of
feel it you can perceive and I think
that's really how the two of us found
our way through this movie some asked me
when was the first time you came in
contact with slavery and I couldn't
remember um any I could remember and it
was a question was like when did you
first know your name I think in a way as
a child as a young
to realize that you know your ancestors
some of your ancestors were slaves and
you was was for me kind of huge thing
yeah well I think I must have been I
mean I remember being very embarrassed
and very ashamed in a way and to start
off life as a person like that I think
it's kind of I never thought of it
before but it must have some sort of
effect on on your outlook on life what
it was about I wanted that every
footprint of Solomon was your the
audience's footprint what he saw you saw
that was that that I just loved that
idea of that first-hand account in the
book but also as I turn the page of the
book I had that same experience
everything he did that I didn't know
what was coming next and I think that
was wanting the audience to be with
Solomon that you were Sullivan I live in
Amsterdam so you know Anne Frank is all
around us
and when I read that book it was like
reading I'm Frank for the first time I
was a kid at school you know it was it
was every page was a revelation every
page was sort of an insight into an
horrendous act will end act whatever in
this time in history in a sense I was
aware of the responsibility of it you
know when I first went Steve first sent
me the script I know you know I just
felt you know there was just a lot of
things in it that I you know I when I
read it I was just stunned by it you
know and I stunned by this story I was
stunned by this character and this time
and I was and I felt the kind of the
responsibility of that the
responsibility not only to Solomon and
to Solomon's descendants in that the
very specific responsibilities but then
also to tell a story from inside the
slave experience in this way was
something that I had never experienced
that I'd never seen he didn't take a
very long time but I realized ultimately
as I went back to the book and I went
back to the script that there was
something about Solomon that I felt I
needed to connect with that actually I
if I could find out about him and
connect to him somehow and I didn't have
to worry about the wider implications of
everything I just had to tell his story
and I
that in the journey of him revealing
himself to me in in the book and and
then the sort of growing appreciation
and understanding that I had for him as
an individual it allowed me to try and
compelled me to try and find him
artistically one of the things that we
tend to resist in terms of subject
matter as Americans is anything placed
in the slave era but the truth is that
we for most of our history for 300 years
of our history were a slave economy and
that's longer than we've been anything
else but we don't want to not only look
at that but we don't want to hear about
a person whether it's Solomon or another
person during that period because of
guilt and shame and anger and all those
things but what happens is you have a
society that that is not embracing or
claiming the majority of its history and
so we get surprised when verdicts go in
particular way and they do polls and
everybody says you think that you think
that it's because it's me it's as if
someone is 21 they've moved to New York
they change their name and deny the fact
they have a childhood
they might rise in the ranks of some
company they might be very important but
they're always gonna be off balance and
they're always gonna trip and not
understand themselves and so one of the
things that I think that 12-years offers
us one of the the great possibilities is
that Steve I feel like you have painted
such a realistic and complex landscape a
reality that we haven't seen before that
there's there's enough people and
there's not circumstances that all of us
could imagine ourselves in it whereas
before we would always be at a distance
and something about imagining ourselves
in it and imagining our people that we
have come from in it makes it real makes
us embrace allows us to embrace it and
so we can see each other's point of view
more readily
we have watched it unfold all of us
together and hopefully there will be a
common language that we can start to to
listen to each other up